d'autres mondes c'est ce quiz il ajouté
nous sommes pas en boîte de nuit mais
nous sommes sur 13 fusion tout
fraîchement sorti sur xbox one psk pc
xbox 360 est actuellement ni joue sur
ps4 alors piloté créé classement à des
options yoplait contenu supplémentaire
bas et des options voyons c'est tout ce
qu'on veut dans un jeu allait piloter le
sérieux le sérieux avant tout un jeu
propose qu'on s'attaque tout de suite
aux courses les plus hardcore de la
planète qui augmente légèrement mais
attention pour pas dire énormément on a
le choix entre trois motos et le quad un
peu de vapeur ne sait ce dont tu es
qu'avec une bonne dose de précisions
alors les défis à on a des défis dans
chaque course mais là honnêtement on
s'en bat les steaks
j'ai pas le niveau pour faire la course
meubles sont les défis locaux attention
la première chute d'ici quelques
instants
et voilà allez allez je m'en vais aller
je pars en nageant ok j'ai des génies
des génies des arêtes de mais [ __ ] tu
veux l'excédent le plus nul du monde
quoi arrête ne panique pas c'est normal
ne panique pas hop là
non mais comment voulez vous ne voulez
j'aime les plats comme état mais chut
chut c'est quoi ce jeu là taille à un
pack un bug
j'adore être que mes joueurs allez on
retourne au point de départ ou dans les
flammes ou ici un style aussi lequel
nickel nickel comme avait seulement je
suis sur la plate à
j'y ai cru j'ai tellement cru ah mais
attendez je peux pas passer le
checkpoint en faisant un truc attendez
on va tenter hop
non si on fait une figure en l'air ça
passe pas mieux oooh
mais comment j'ai fait mais je n'en sais
rien mais je suis passé à ces sarsgaard
et a tellement été impressionné qu'il
est tombé la colline derrière up bas
sénécal ce piège c'est parfait a laissé
l'europe toujours arriver nickel c'est
quand même la médaille de bronze avec
seulement 49 fautes temps n'était pas de
la médaille d'argent il faut 15 fautes
pour la médaille d'argent tu es pas on
va faire un petit fmx
donc là on va devoir marquer le plus de
points en faisant des figures attention
voilà temps mais ok mais je suis pas
d'accord donc déjà des gens en a perdu
101 milles point de vue autre genre
assez la lune ça c'est ma figure préféré
c'est la lune
auger cru j'ai comme taggers mais c'est
pas mal on continue on continue aux
figures nikkei a les attendent et on va
faire un truc astier voilà l'homme en
harmonie avec la machine oui et non un
slide oui voilà c'était compris dans le
deal ok la tecktonik en l'air superman
superman encore plus c'est superman
coincé médaille d'or
allez on va faire un petit jeu d'adressé
quelle altitude peux-tu atteindre sans
faire de faute
michael tu passes tu passes tu payes tu
t'en ailles ces îles sont pas à ton
niveau pourquoi pourquoi tu prête
attention à eux le pire départ de la
planète terre hop là bas je pensais que
j'étais copain avec moi les baril mais
vous m'avez trahi très bien mais je
retiens je retiens à [ __ ] on la
dompteuse là on l'attend mais [ __ ]
barils voilà c'est l'hélicoptère s'agit
manière de plus en plus j'ai de moins en
moins loin la date
yes on esquive et les eaux voilà
aujourd'hui faire la gueule j'aurais dû
faire la gueule c'est pas grave on est
posée là on est posée ok nikkei oh je
découvre une nouvelle partie de la
[ __ ] pourquoi j'ai parlé ni calebasse
et bien c'est bien chez on a fait une
médaille d'argent
moi je trouve ça honorable je suis prêt
à y aller je me fais juste quelques
abdos sur le guidon voilà comme ça
on laisse le monsieur qui me parle dans
leurs essaims jaloux ça passe ou ça
passe haut la petite femme de là-bas
vous a vu c'était mignon restée la barre
hausse est de courbure cette courbure
comme ça ou s'ils avaient d'ailleurs ces
médailles d'or ok donc ça c'est un rider
écolo un peu quand même
oh ça mais qu'il a pris un choc 2 août
dans le bide et il est en vie et des
fois juste qui fait sa job heures au oui
c'est sa convenance pas ça qu'on veut a
battu un petit moment où tu crois que tu
vas t'en sortir et puis non aux plats on
amortit le choc et d'optique cuisse hop
là on amortit le grand choc avec nos
petits bras
je suis dis dans mes cachets je peux
arrêter de jouer sans colle je ne me
repère le moteur caché dans les fougères
je t'ai vu oui j'arrive km avec les
médailles jeu je sens lors hop la
médaille d'or
souple et vous plaît en un mot comme
faut être gentil avec moi que j'expose
facile alors mr banquise
je suis prêt à combattre [ __ ] minutes
un métier ce début de course de fois où
le pot départ des fois des chocs de la
gueule mais c'est monstrueux
hop non mais je me suis fait mal en haut
de la cuisse
tu peux m'aider lumière rouge je m'en
bats les couilles merci beaucoup
rien et les gros coup de bassin qui
donne au live
il en tombe au non ça c'est dégueu la
voilà allez double backflip raide comme
un mort regardez comment ces formats
route tap dance à la sem étages et j'ai
serré les doigts de pied quoi si vous
vraiment que je très énervé aller parce
ça joue sur les nerfs
as tu fais pas c'est à juarez élections
c'est bien la taper là je suis fier de
toi on ne voit presque pas bon j'avoue
on doit carrément va te cacher aux plats
allégés le sou salut je vole passe le
cube et plonge au plateau mot gratuit
allez c'est parti c'est qu'il suivant
oui elle était pas office pourquoi t'es
pas versé au vert
/ ajoute j'ai tant rêvé d'elle de
l'arrivée c'est d'elle que je parle à
santo mes symptômes aigus doit pied vont
mourir on a eu la langue verte
finalement oui oh non il ya une super
combinaisons mais ça va cube
j'essaie de nager actuellement sur toi
ça dérange je prends comme un oui bah
ouais non non non la veille a aucun
problème
puis je suis xtor fait cette moto mick
quitter comme ça sur mes yeux mais vatin
voilà moi aussi je te tue qu'est ce qui
est un pas du coup c'est moi qui me fait
tiquer mais bon c'est l'arrivée j'en
suis sûr c'est l'arrivée c'est la fin le
bateau coule
tout ça pour faire couler un bateau mais
qui se fait chier à faire tout ça pour
faire couler un bateau pourquoi il a
tout simplement
et ça dès le départ jeux sans médaille
d'or à hop là la médaille d'or nickel
pas se passe
et voilà et ça y est je suis le demeurer
avec comme ça passe passe passe mollo
non mais tu veux pas passer moi je m'en
fous je m'en fous bon tu as gagné
attends ça me gratte un peu la nuque
nickel on y retourne
tu m'as fait peur moto je suis sûr que
ça va sourire voilà et hop on y va dit
c'était le fun
qu'est ce qu'il a il fait du blau pas
visible
je peux avoir c'est edouard je ne veux
pas voir ça au coût que tu fais ça tu as
pas de cerceaux autour de la taille
arrêts et doit ce n'est pas parce que
t'as pas de service auto la taille que
tu te crois dans une piscine c'est ça la
là tu peux nager parvient le plus loin
possible sans te pencher mais on peut
freiner d'accord très bien mais c'est
très drôle de bloquer le pansement d'une
personne comme ça anne et saint ouen ou
à ses conseils mes doigts de pieds de
redevienne un peu un peu dur là non mais
non mais non c'est parti on doit faire
le plus de tricks possible on commence
direct avec mon tricks favoris qui n'est
pas du tout basé sur la chance en plus
de ça voilà la regarder notre score
adjacent
j'avais déjà sentais pas résultats mais
médaille de bronze voilà mérité une
médaille d'or celle non non et si nous
roulions notre pilote vous allez faire
un petit style un bon style en fait un
bail qui ne lui va mais alors pas du
tout non tu passes ta déjà vu combien
temps ça peut durer ce petit jeu mais tu
fais chier [ __ ] phoques et résister
me voici un red shoes up violent tuent
pas stupas j'ai plus envie de jouer avec
toi
s'il te plait je vais arriver un jour
non mais sincèrement j'ai un verre jour
un jour on est qu'on en était un jour
d'hiver face il propose que d'un coup on
s'en aille ou alors qu'on chope ce robot
et compte tu [ __ ] lui mer rouge via
les rouges bien pourquoi je tourne la
tête [ __ ] donc noté rien vu dans les
rues c'est un bientôt je vais jouer
comme ça également ou alors mais bon là
là là on est bon c'est là que j'ai
arrivent oh oui oh oui au fait
non mais là la suge de 3 gens peu plus
et voilà les gens c'est déjà la fin de
cette petite vidéo sur très hautes mais
rassurez vous je ne veux plus jamais
entendre parler d'une moto à à part
celle ci oui oui alors oui maman oui
j'ai la chance aujourd'hui de pouvoir
faire gagner 5 cry ou de fusion sur pc
ça se passe dans la description cliquer
sur le lien
samedi concours sur deux comme quoi en
fait bonne chance à tous et merci
d'avoir regardé cette vidéo n'hésitez
pas à les baisser elle vous a plu à tout
le monde
[Musique]
et